I have video for you today of rages
lunatic pastore While Who Says He Was
Made Sick by someone Else
vaccine This Is Another Guy Who claims
that There Will People shadding
Around
How does the sky even get the work in
the morning
For The First Time In Human  History
Global genocide wow
Friends 2017
coming in the
The North Korean wrap was Cause by gay
People he Said People There gonna die
Because of gay Marriage he Said That a
Some Kind of numerology Thing proofs
Barack Obama Killed Supreme Court Justin
inscolia he Said vegan Burgers are
Titanic Plug To Destroy The Souls of
People he Said I Trump is remove There
Would Be Violence um he will in a Said
I'm In Listen Trump last She Was A
removed and There Was violent but it was
the Trump is he want a Duke True  to
remove Trump and now he says that It was
the vaccinated person the one
thactionated person that Made Everybody
second now we have set Before there is
no way to be affacted in Anyway by
People Around You B  eing vaccinated with
the Coated vaccines use in the United
States other than Your Last lightly The
thief People around you are actuated If
You are Secret covid Your Body can
released particles of the virus When You
Come
If You Are vaccinated With awax scene
that can taines live  virus There is a
Shore period of Time during With You
Could Be shutting divirus Nothing of the
Coated Back scenes use than the United
States use live lyrics there is no
physiological Mechanism for that happen
with the Coated vaccines in using the
United States You Can have viral  shading
after about scene if it is a live virus
vaccine the US is not using such Back
scenes ehm and but It Doesn't Matter
Rick wild is he convinced is this Just
Say It I don't know but More Dangerous
ant-vaccine is there  Any good news well
Lightning to good news is morn more
people that beingetting Back To The Last
couple weaks The Numbers got so low They
are increasing that's a good thing and
Let's hope that it  continues also Let's
hope The David badmint show continues
paster 16 vers 3 The 16th anniversary
coming up on Monday August find ze
kan bier Incredible Day and historic
Day and We are also Deep this counting
are website membership Son That Day We
Wanna Polly in a record number  People I
think The Record for single Day new
membership this Something like Five it
in the 500 And that happened quite
sometimed Girl We Wanna Do a single They
record for new members you can get on my
mailing list The David packman.com and
Monday morning You  Will Be notify
One of responders today is Blue Chew a
Unique online service to deliver the
same Active ingredients as viagra and
sealis in a jebalform Another fraction
of the Cost en There giving My arabians
and entire Months Supply For Free So if
you think you could benefit  from an
extra boost of confidence When It's Time
All You Have To Do Us take a short quiz
under website a license doctor
approvezer prescription the medicatio  n
Come strated your home with is in a
discreet package no driving Around to
the Doctors Office Little pharmacy no
Waiting Around Now Awkward conversations
with your Doctor All Of Blue Shoes
tablets Are Made in the US say The
entire process Just A few clicks go to
Bluetooth  that Come The link is
Underneath this video del Give You and
en Tire Months Supply For Free when you
use the Promo Code Pacman All you have
to do is Pay 5 Daughters Shipping